CARLSON TONIGHT."
JUST ABOUT A DECADE AGO GENDER
DYSPHORIA WAS A SHORT ENTRY IN
ABNORMAL PSYCHOLOGY TEXTBOOKS.
THAT'S CHANGED.
IF YOU HAVE CHILDREN IN SCHOOL
YOU KNOW HOW COMMON THAT
DISORDER HAS BECOME.
A THIRD OF GIRLS IN A GIVEN
CLASS IDENTIFY AS A GENDER OTHER
THAN THE ONE ON THEIR BIRTH
CERTIFICATE.
FIVE YEARS FROM NOW THEY WILL
HAVE MOVED ON.
THEY ARE GOING THROUGH A PHASE.
FOR A LARGE NUMBER OF CHILDREN
THAT PHASE WON'T END.
THEIR PARENTS WILL STEER THEM TO
DOCTORS WHO WILL GIVE THEM SEX
HORMONES.
IN SOME CASES THOSE KIDS WILL BE
REFERRED TO SURGEONS WHO REMOVE
THEIR SEX ORGANS.
THAT'S HAPPENING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TONIGHT.
WE RARELY TALK ABOUT THE
DETAILS.
IT'S ALL GOOD.
PART OF THE LONG OVERDUE PROCESS
OF PERSONAL LIBERATION.
IF YOU ASK TOO MANY QUESTIONS
YOU ARE EVIL.
BEFORE WE ACCEPT THAT VERSION,
IS IT FAIR TO ASK WHAT ARE THE
DETAILS OF THE PROCESS EXACTLY?
WHAT ARE THE CONSEQUENCES OF IT?
THIS WEEKEND TO ITS GREAT CREDIT
"60 MINUTES" ASKED THOSE
QUESTIONS IN AN UNFLINCHING WAY.
LESLEY STAHL ASKED WHAT HAPPENS
NEXT?
HERE IS A WOMAN EXPLAINING WHAT
SHE WENT THROUGH AFTER GOING TO
A DOCTOR TO TREAT HER DISORDER.
>> SHE DIDN'T GONE INTO MY
GENDER DYSPHORIA STEMMED FROM.
THEY ASKED WHY DO YOU WANT TO GO
ON TESTOSTERONE?
WELL, BEING A WOMAN IS NOT
WORKING.
THEY SAID OKAY.
>> THAT WAS THAT.
YOU GOT A PRESCRIPTION FOR
TESTOSTERONE?
>> YES.
>> Tucker: THAT'S ALL IT TOOK.
IT KEPT GOOING.
WITHIN 4 MONTHS SHE WAS IN THE
OPERATING ROOM HAVING A DOUBLE
MASTECTOMY.
>> SHE SAID APPROVED FOR
A MASTECTOMY, TOP SURGERY, SHE
TOLD US WAS TRAUMATIC.
>> I STARTED TO HAVE A REALLY
DISTURBING SENSE THAT A PART OF
MY BODY WAS MISSING.
LIKE A GHOST LIMB FEELING.
SOMETHING SHOULD BE THERE.
IT SURPRISED ME BUT IT WAS
REALLY HARD TO DENY.
>> SO, SHE DE-TRANSITIONED BY
GOING OFF TESTOSTERONE AND THEN
WENT BACK TO THE CLINIC AND
COMPLAINED TO THE DOCTOR THAT
THE PROCESS DIDN'T FOLLOW THE
GUIDELINES.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE I
TRANSITIONED AND DE-TRANSITIONED
IN THE COURSE OF LIKE LESS THAN
ONE YEAR.
IT'S CRAZY.
>> Tucker: YES, IT IS.
IT'S ALSO RECKLESS AND CRUEL AND
TOTALLY UNETHICAL.
IN A NEW ATMOSPHERE FOR AMERICAN
MEDICINE IT'S ROUTINE.
ANOTHER PERSON SPOKE TO "60
MINUTES" AND TOLD LESLEY STAHL
THAT DOCTORS RUSHED HIM INTO
A SEX CHANGE OPERATION AFTER
JUST 3 MONTHS OF TAKING FEMALE
HORMONES.
THEY CASTRATED HIM.
>> GARRETT FROM LOUISIANA WENT
FROM TAKING HORMONES TO GETTING
HIS TESTICLES REMOVED IN JUST 3
MONTHS.
THE CURRENT GUIDELINES CALL FOR
CONTINUE
OUS USE FOR.
>> I WAS NOT SUICIDAL AND ABOUT
A WEEK AFTERWARD I WANTED TO
KILL MYSELF.
I HAD A PLAN AND I WAS GOING TO
DO IT.
I KEPT THINKING ABOUT LIKE MY
FAMILY TO STOP MYSELF.
IT FELT LIKE HOW WILL I EVER
FEEL NORMAL AGAIN LIKE OTHER
GUYS NOW?
>> Tucker: 3 MONTHS TO
CASTRATION AND A WEEK AFTER THE
SURGERY, HE WANTED TO KILL
HIMSELF.
THAT MAKES SENSE AND YET IT IS
THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT ACTIVISTS
GAME.
THE JUSTIFICATION FOR THESE
PROCEDURES IN THE FIRST PLACE.
IF YOU ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
WISDOM WILL GENDER REASSIGNMENT
SURGERY YOU ARE ACCUSED OF
PUSHING THEM TO SELF HARM.
THERE IS EVIDENCE OF THE
OPPOSITE.
GENDER REASSIGNMENT SURGERY
CAUSE DEPRESSION.
5 YEARS AGO A STUDY BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION FOUND NO POSITIVE
HEALTH BENEFITS FROM THIS
TREATMENT.
IN 2016 IN A DOCUMENT OBAMA
OFFICIALS CONCLUDED THAT BASED
ON A THOROUGH REVIEW OF THE
CLINICAL EVIDENCE THERE IS NOT
ENOUGH EVIDENCE TO DETERMINE IF
GENDER REASSIGNMENT HEALTH
SURGERY PROVIDES BENEFITS.
MANY SEX CHANGE PATIENTS WERE
LOST TO FOLLOW-UP.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY HAD KILLED
THEMSELVES.
RESEARCHES IN SWEDEN FOUND THE
SAME THING.
PEOPLE WERE 19% MORE LIKELY TO
COMMIT SUICIDE.
IT WAS AN UTTER DISASTER.
MOST AMERICANS ARE NOT AWARE OF
THESE NUMBERS.
THEY HAVE NEVER SEEN THIS
RESEARCH.
THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED TO SEE IT.
THEY SEE A DAILY BARRAGE OF
PROPAGANDA ON THE MEDIA AND
FACEBOOK.
WATCH.
>> HOW MANY OF YOU FEEL YOU WERE
BLINDLY AFFIRMED?
>> I DIDN'T GET ENOUGH PUSH BACK
ON TRANSITIONING.
I WENT FOR TWO APPOINTMENTS.
AFTER THE SECOND ONE I HAD MY
LETTER TO GO GET ON HORMONES.
>> ALL FOUR TELL US THEY LEARNED
ABOUT TRANSITIONING ON THE
INTERNET WHERE THERE ARE
TRANSFORMATION VIDEOS ON youTUBE
AND FORUMS.
>> Tucker: WE HAVE NOT SAID A
LOT OF COMPLIMENTARY THINGS
ABOUT LESLEY STAHL ON THIS SHOW
BUT THIS WAS A BRAVE PIECE OF
JOURNALISM.
GOOD FOR HER.
SHE IS BEING PUNISHED FOR IT
NOW.
WITHIN MINUTES OF THAT BROADCAST
THE LIARS ACCUSED LESLEY STAHL
AND THE PEOPLE SHE INTERVIEWED
OF COMMITTING AN ACT OF
VIOLENCE.
THOSE ATTACKS HAVE A CHILLY
EFFECT ON THE REST OF THE
POPULATION.
WATCH THIS PSYCHOLOGIST DESCRIBE
HOW MANY IN MEDICINE ARE AFRAID
TO CARE FOR THEIR PATIENTS.
>> DO YOU HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH YOUR COLLEAGUES ABOUT THIS
AREA OF ACCEPTING WHAT YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE SAYING TOO READILY?
>> YES, EVERYONE IS AFRAID TO
SPEAK UP BECAUSE WE ARE SEEN AS
DOING SOMETHING TO HURT THE
TRANS-COMMUNITY.
>> Tucker: WE ARE AFRAID TO
SPEAK UP BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
TO BE SEEN AS NOT AFFIRMING
YOUNG PEOPLE.
HOW YOUNG?
AT WHAT AGE DO WE HAVE TO
RESPECT THEIR PERSONAL DECISION
TO UNDERGO CHEMICAL CASTRATION.
LAST YEAR JOE BIDEN SUGGESTED
THAT CHILDREN AS YOUNG AS 8 CAN
CHANGE THEIR SEX.
>> THE IDEA THAT AN 8-YEAR-OLD
OR 10-YEAR-OLD CHILD DECIDES I
WANT TO BE TRANSGENDER.
IT WOULD MAKE MY LIFE A LOT
EASIER.
THERE SHOULD BE ZERO
DISCRIMINATION.
>> Tucker: THINGS ARE MOVING
AWFULLY FAST AND MOST PEOPLE
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THE DETAILS
ARE.